I don't know anything about cricket
there's no real crickets in it the bat
is called a wicket the wickets the ball
I believe when I think about cricket I
think about the outfits that they're
wearing shorts and like a jacket or
something seems very proper so I guess
there's a lot of different accessories
for your cricket outfit the entire time
that we have been talking about cricket
I've been envisioning croquet it's like
squash had a baby with baseball so Green
is Pakistan blue is India there's
someone wearing blue there's someone
wearing red and there's someone wearing
black and I think only two teams are
playing there's a cow on the field it's
at a Mountie that must be the rev he's
looks like a Canadian Mountie he's
definitely not called an umpire I know
that I think what are the bar is in the
middle that's a sign battalion does it
sign something this means something I'm
not really sure where the bases are
still have no clue how they acquire
points it's like there are no
outfielders so maybe the goal is not to
like catch the ball he's trying to hit
the ball along the ground well then why
were they so excited before when they
went far away I have no idea what's
going on here this is very confusing
where where are they trying to get the
ball it feels like it can go anywhere
there's a lovely shot it rolled towards
like a line that looked like a warning
track and baseball I know less now about
cricket than I knew before we watched it
I think it looks dope I don't even know
how many rounds there are like what how
many point Ron's we didn't even know
what I'm definitely not gonna like a
lookout for it on yes B n like any sport
with Cowboys could probably easily
become second nature to me eventually
[Music]
[Music]